you know is with us in Columbia South
Carolina
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Lena hi
thanks for having me sure what's up well
I just wanted to get your advice I have
a parent who is financially
irresponsible I'm trying to prepare for
the inevitable request for money or to
cosign on a loan and I don't want any
additional debt and I'm only on baby
step two in the program I signed up for
the Financial Peace University and I'm
working through the material how old are
you what if I'm 30 and how old is your
parent 65 mom yes okay um well the first
thing I want you to do is I'm going to
send you a copy of a book called
boundaries and the boundaries allows you
to put boundaries between you and any
relative that is requesting something
that is unreasonable okay okay
and it's not that we don't love them if
she wanted you to give her money to buy
cocaine you would not do that that's an
unreasonable request correct right right
absolutely so you would throw up a
boundary immediately so it's not
unloving to put up boundaries it as a
matter of fact in that case it would be
loving because we're not going to allow
her to destroy your life we're not going
to participate in her destroying our
life and so we're not going to
participate financially in insanity
we're not going to participate
financially in enabling by giving a
drunk a drink so somehow we've got to be
a blessing to mom because we love her
right and that's what boundaries will
help you grasp because the father are
the daughter mother relationship is one
of the most difficult to say no to
because moms in this scenario are often
travel agents for guilt trips oh yes she
will sign you up for a guilt trip they
are good at it and they don't mean to be
it's just how they function you know so
anyway so let's lay down a couple of
boundaries number one is if she were to
call
asked you to co-sign the answer simply
know now the way I would answer her is
mom you know I know you've been doing
stuff this way your whole life and I've
been going through a financial class and
I've decided I don't borrow money
anymore and so that means I can't sign
on any notes anymore because I don't
borrow money for anything ever
well that's crazy I know you think that
mom I understand that but I don't borrow
money more so I will be unable to
co-sign I just can't and the answer is
simply no you cannot because co-signing
100 percent of time is a stupid idea
because it's a problem you're gonna get
yourself in a problem okay now do we
want to help her with some money
possibly possibly if it takes her down a
path that causes her to win okay and
she's 65 years old does she have an
income but she work no okay he's on
disability she lives on her disability
okay so we have a fixed income and
that's a tight income to start with but
then on top of that it gets tighter
because she is disorganized and
misbehaves with it right okay so
probably help her to go through the
financial piece class you think okay as
an executive really yeah it's only as
well I wouldn't be willing to give her
money if she wasn't willing and I'll pay
for her to go through if I was her son
okay okay and so it would sound like mom
you know what I can probably help you
with this bill and if you need you know
you need $200 to pay this bill I can I
can do that I'll help you okay but the
only way I'm going to help you is if you
go and learn some of this stuff I've
been learning and so because I'm worried
about your mom and I want you to do I
want you to be good with money and I
want you to have fun again
and you haven't you haven't had fun with
money in a long time mom and I really
want you to win and I just love you so
much and so I'm going to pay for this
and I'm going to give you the $200 but
I'm not going to give you $200 if you
don't promise to go to class because I
want you to I want good things for you
this is I see that now if she gets mad
at that
then she's got other issues doesn't she
absolutely and she might have other fish
because sometimes people don't like that
you know
but I'm unwilling to give a drunk a
drink I am I am willing to help them to
win long-term I'm unwilling to
participate in her continued misbehavior
but with money by just giving her money
and bailing her out because that doesn't
change your habits we've got to change
your habits with some new information
and that means going last and that's
good you know because she's only 65 she
came in 30 years right and died 30 years
on a disability income you got to really
watch what you're doing
and so and then over on your side of the
equation you just walk your baby steps
and you do the stuff you're supposed to
be doing handling money the way we're
teaching you to handle money and as you
build wealth you're going to be more and
more able to help and it not bother your
finances but even then you know I'm
multi-millionaire I can do anything I
want to do with money financially
virtually within reason to help somebody
but even then we're very careful when we
help someone that we actually are
helping them and we're not participating
in their insanity right and so I don't
want to enable exactly and so you know
Dave that's tough love no it's just love
all love has a tough element to it it's
is it tough love to make your kid learn
to brush their teeth no it's just love
if you want to have teeth in their head
when they're older you know you know one
brought out of the head so it's a tough
love to make your kid do their homework
well if you want to call it that you can
but I just call it love because they
need to be able to study so they can get
good grades and get out and you know
earn a living and so on and so it's just
loving people around us well but it's
easier just to throw money at stuff
it doesn't require any emotional
investment and what I'm asking you to do
is even harder than just throwing money
at something does that make sense that
does and I do want to I want to help her
and I want to see her succeed they're
going what I want to see you're
struggling but at the same time you know
want to avoid the guilt ships I think
that that response I think that's very
reasonable and that's different so I
think it is and if she um if she
responds poorly to it it might be
temporary it might be she just sees she
may throw a little hissy fit
if it'll push you over the edge you know
that she may try that that's not unusual
when you put up a boundary so be ready
for it you're not crazy you're not
unloving you're sane and loving and
that's what I'm telling you and that's
what the book boundaries will remind you
of so hold on Kelly will pick up we'll
send you a copy of that so many people
like almost every one of us listening
deal with something like this at some
point in your life you have someone a
friend or relative or whatever that is
inappropriate in their approach to help
that they're soliciting and man I have
made some people mad had a guy drop in
here one time at the front desk a
stranger off the street and he said I'm
I need to see Dave Ramsey God told me
this morning that Dave was going to give
me a van a new van for my family and I
they called me I went out front I said I
don't talk to him and he said God told
me that you were going to give me a van
and I said no he didn't he said we mean
I said no he didn't because I talked to
God every morning and if God told me
that I was to give you a van there be
one sitting out here with car keys in it
and he didn't tell me and so that's not
God you're talking to us last night's
pizza or you're a manipulative twerp I'm
not sure which it is but you've got a
problem on your own your spiritual
hearing because God did not tell me to
buy you a van and so guess what you're
not getting a van today he was angry I'm
not a real Christian Dave Ramsey's not a
real Christian can you imagine him
saying that to me isn't it I've hurt my
little feelings for about like not at
all because I knew that's what was
coming I mean of all the dad-blamed gall
to walk into a place and say God told me
as if he's the only one that talks to
God
I mean people some people's kids I mean
unbelievable but when you set boundaries
with people that have inappropriate
boundaries sometimes you get an angry
response don't you because they're
because you're just supposed to bow down
because they said so
because I said so moms and dads brothers
and sisters it team members employees
employers quote-unquote friends even
sometimes god help us preachers do it
violate boundaries and that's why Henry
clouds sold about eight million of those
boundaries books right there there's a
bunch of folk that need them this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh